bride-to-be palak Pancham aya thought
she'd already picked her dream dress but
after taking a closer look at their
budget palak and her fiance decided to
make some savings meaning another trip
to the clothes rack to bring the market
scenario right no there is a little
recession in India as well going on
so considering this starting phase we've
consciously tried to cut down on the
cost by effectively 20 30 % Indian
weddings are renowned for being lavish
glitzy Affairs with hundreds or even
thousands of guests partying for days on
end but despite being seen as
recession-proof the industry has also
fallen victim to India's slumping
economy only it used to be a week-long
weddings has now been converted to just
one or one and a half day or wedding in
the entire family is being dreaming
about early day one day when my child
would get marry and they've been saving
things for that day this sector has had
the major setback the wedding size which
used to be 2,000 people has been reduced
to now 700-800 scaling back on the big
day can impact friendships and social
standing people who'd normally make the
guest list now find themselves left off
it for another bride-to-be man Vita
Khurana it's a real worry if all the
businesses you look over look anywhere
in India are down so you know it that
really affects each and every family it
doesn't only affect the bride in the
room it also affects the siblings around
the relatives around because then what
happens we could start you know cutting
the costs down the picture-perfect
wedding maybe getting a slim down but
it's still sure to be full of all the
color and emotion that's the hallmark of
any marriage in India let's bring in a
tree shan't Silvani he's directed at
dreams craft a wedding services company
based in Mumbai to shop glad you could
join us now due to the slowdown in the
Indian economy couples having to cut
back on their wedding expenses how
exactly are they going
doing this the economy is on a little
bit of a slowdown and I think it all
ends up trickling into the wedding
industry not directly but a little
indirectly so Indians in general are
used to you know saving money for their
children's marriage I think it's sort of
in their blood to save money from it
from the time a child is born for the
grant celebrations of their kids
weddings but what happens is that this
money is actually not liquid always
right I mean it's always put in stocks
in in real estate or wherever else they
might pump that money but then with the
prices of everything going down and that
that sort of money becomes non liquid
able after a point so the the funds that
are deployed towards the wedding tend to
go down and we're seeing that happening
in the in the wedding industry as well
so while people are are you know taking
their time to sort of invest they're you
know they're taking the time to put
money in say a five-star hotel and you
know trying to keep their status intact
the other services within the wedding
tend to get affected so they would spend
a little less money on say the decor
aspect of it they would probably reduce
the amount of money that they spend on
alcohol they probably you know take the
lower end brands there and and then
they'll they probably go from an a-plus
artist to an a-lister or a beer b lister
artist to perform at their weddings
that's that's some place we're seeing
the major impact coming in what does
that mean for companies such as jaws
clearly weddings are very important to
indians are you able to deliver the
extravagance that people demand of you
but at a cheaper rate no I don't think
that is really possible because what
cost money it costs money so we have
seen a cutback in terms of budget of
every individual line from India but
they what how we have as a company is
that we've done we tend we've sort of
focused on doing a lot more weddings in
quantity and also focused on getting
weddings from the overseas market into
India so we focusing a lot on NRI
weddings who are looking to come back to
their roots
married you spoke about quantity I just
like to sort of talk about that just so
our viewers can get a clearer picture
what is the biggest wedding with the
biggest number of people you all have
ever organized so we've organized a
wedding for 25,000 people as well so I
mean that that's just one team of people
so it's it's really not about how much
how many people are actually part of the
event it's about how extravagant you can
go or to really create that experience
for even 200 people so we've had
weddings where we've had only 200 people
attending but the the scale of the
wedding is its massive like I mean when
the artists are performing it's like
it's like the kind of artists that
perform at weddings these days is other
kind who would you who you would buy a
ticket and go and watch at a concert so
that's the scale at which the weddings
go in India quarter-scale trishanne
Silvani thanks so much for laying it out
for us